These prototype gloves turn colors when they
detect harmful chemicals in the air.
And a vaccine to treat the relapse of heroin
addiction has been proven effective in drug
addicted rats and they're working on starting
human trials...
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
A six inch skeleton found 10 years ago in
Chile has finally been proven to be human
remains and not as some had claimed - an alien.
Gary Nolan an immunologist at Stanford University
discovered the DNA was modern and high quality,
indicating that it's only a few decades old
and undoubtedly human. He concluded that the
bones were around the age of a 6-8 year old
and he hypothesizes that he or she either
died in the womb and suffered from a rapid
aging disorder or less likely lived with a
severe form of dwarfism to that age.
TweetPee lets parents know when their baby
has peed. Using a device that measures moisture
and looks like a twitter bird, its been developed
for huggies diapers in Brazil. The sensor
measures the wetness and alerts parents with
a tweet or text message when their baby has
peed.
Terrafugia of Massachusetts is working on
making a flying car for the everyday person.
The TF-X will take off vertically like a helicopter
then once in the air rotor blades drop and
a rear mounted gas engine takes over. The
computer in the flying car lands it for you
and there is an emergency parachute if needed.It
has a nonstop flight range of 500 miles and
should only take 5 or so hours for the average
person to learn how to use. They expect to
start selling it around 2020 and assume the
price will be similar to any high end luxury
car.
Brightest explosion ever observed! (35 billion
times brighter than visible light and 3.6
billion light years away)
Students from Royal College of Art in London
developed a set of headphones that can enhance
the user's sight and hearing. One device is
a mask that sits over the mouth and ears where
a directional microphone captures audio and
is processed to neutralize background noise.
It's then passed through to the listener so
it's as if there is someone talking inside
your head. Applications are for the hearing
impaired and possibly to help children with
ADHD focus in classrooms. The second fits
over the eyes and allows the user to see special
effects. Head mounted cameras captures imagery
where it is processed and played to the wearer.
Applications would be helpful for sports teams
(events) and performing arts.
The Bounce Imaging Explorer helps first responders
evaluate dangerous situations before having
to go in themselves. Developed by Francisco
Aguilar it has a shock absorbing shell with
6 cameras. LED's to light up dark rooms, and
a digital microphone. After synching it to
a smartphone or tablet, you throw the ball
into the dangerous area. It immediately begins
to take pictures and testing for toxins and
high temperatures. Aguilar hopes it can be
used by police, firefighters, soldiers, search
and rescue teams, and industrial inspections.
New sundew species of meat eating plant found
in Japan
Xerox plans on rolling out Ignite, a service
that turns copiers, scanners, and printers
into paper grading machines. Not only will
it be able to grade papers like the commonly
used scantron system, it will have the ability
to turn right and wrong answers into web accessible
data that will let teachers know whether a
student or group of students are consistently
having trouble with certain math problems.
Making it easier for the teacher to plan lessons
and help specific students in certain areas
and tailoring homework to the academic strengths
and weaknesses.
The Pallas long tongued bat eats using a really
long blood-swollen tongue. They have tiny
hairs along their tongues that engorge with
blood when they need to get nectar from a
plant. The hairs act sort of like a mop grabbing
as much nectar as possible with each swipe.
Previously biologists thought the hairs were
inactive and just sat there, but recent studies
have shown they are very active and the process
is the same that makes the male reproductive
organ erect in mammals.
Finally Vincent and Emily created by artists
Nikolas Schmid-Pfahler and Carolin Liebl are
a robotic couple made as an examination of
human relationships that react to signals
around them.
I'm gonna leave you with a legged leaping
robot and as always thanks for watching...
[Ladybug Spreads Its Wings]